-Well, it's been a big
24 hours
for investigations into
Donald Trump and his associates.
The committee probing the
January 6th insurrection
subpoenaed several
key Trump allies,
including his former
personal attorney
and the New York
attorney general
revealed in court documents
that her office had uncovered
evidence of possible fraud
committed by Trump's businesses.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
There were lots of little
known functionaries involved
in Trump's attempted coup,
whose names you might
not remember,
guys like John Eastman,
who wrote the memo laying out
how to overturn the election,
or Jeffrey Clark,
who tried to seize control
of the Justice Department
and announce that there
was fraud in the election.
You don't have to know
their names
to just know these two guys
look like henchmen.
They're the types of guys
you expect
to see playing boar
on the floor with Logan Roy.
[ Laughter ]
I'm shocked.
I'm shocked we didn't see
Cousin Greg
at one of Trump's
press conferences.
"Uh, sir, if I may.
Your eminence, uh,
Tom instructed me
that in no uncertain terms
that, uh, we were not
to promulgate any known
falsehoods on television,
or he would make me
eat, uh,
eat a big bucket of [bleep]."
Look at Greg.
Greg is all grown up.
The time's gonna get there.
That's -- that's what it takes
for a plan like this
to come as close
to succeeding
as it did a bunch of lesser
known functionaries
who will help execute
the plan below the radar.
For example, you might remember
this bashful little wallflower
who conquered his fear
of public speaking
so he could appear
at a few press conferences
after the 2020 election
on Trump's behalf.
-♪ Macho, macho man ♪
-Let's have trial by combat.
That could have
been Mickey Mouse,
that could have been
a dead person.
Do you think we're stupid?
You think we're fools?
Did you all watch
"My Cousin Vinny?"
You know the movie?
-Rudy Giuliani was caught using
an electric shaver,
okay,
out in public
at the airport.
But here's the thing.
He was sitting at the table
eating while he did it.
-First, he had lobster bisque.
Then he began grooming.
-He says to her
how many fingers do I --
"How many fingers do I got up?"
Virginia vote against the man
who dishonored our past
by selling my bedroom.
With a very big spike
in the vote count
at exactly that time,
right up.
I assume Milwaukee
and also in Madison,
voters in a district vote.
We don't have that
kind of subpoena power.
They don't decide the election.
The call for Joe Biden,
isn't --
Who was it called by?
All of then.
Oh, my goodness.
All the networks.
Wow.
-He looked like he just escaped
from Shawshank Prison.
Of course
Rudy would probably crawl
into a random drainage pipe
and end up in prison.
-"Whoa. Whoa, whoa.
A warm bed and a toilet
and the Rita Hayworth post?
How lucky can one guy get?"
As much as we play those clips,
I'll never get over the fact
that that guy
who sounds like the guy
who sprays the shoes
at the bowling alley --
"One for you,
and one for Rudy" --
that guy was once crowned
America's mayor
on magazine covers and became
the personal attorney
to the president
of the United States.
Rudy is what happens
when a scientist
accidentally places
the DNA of a fruit bat,
Mr. Bean,
and yet somehow he ended up
working for the most powerful
person in the world.
You imagine in your head
that the president
has all this power and
information at their fingertips.
They have 17 different
intelligence agencies,
the White House
Situation Room,
an army of government lawyers
and some of the richest,
most powerful people
in the world on their side.
And yet, Trump ended up
with a mole man
who sweats like
he's the defendant.
Rudy sweats like
he's working the pizza oven
in a Spike Lee movie,
Trump told the guy
to hold a press conference
at the Four Seasons Hotel,
and he ended up
at the Four Seasons
landscaping company.
As a career comedy writer,
I got to tip my hat.
I mean, thank God, I never tried
to find any fraud in Vermont.
He would have ended up at
the Burlington Coat Factory.
"Wait a second.
Those aren't voters.
Voters have heads and limbs.
Oh, Rudy,
you've done it again."
Also, I would just like
to circle back
and emphasize once again
that this man is terrible
at impressions.
-One time Bill Clinton asked me,
"What's this guy Romney like?"
You know what I told them?
He's our Al Gore.
-All right, Rudy.
-Mueller's saying,
obstruction of justice.
You cut to him,
obstruction of justice,
which the guy will say,
"Say obstruction of justice."
Obstruction of justice.
I told this to
the Queen of England.
She said, "You did --
you did a wonderful
job on September 11."
"How many fingers do I got up?"
-I'm Spartacus.
-By the way, Biden has been...
-Man, this "SNL" audition sucks.
[ Laughter ]
If Lorne ever saw impressions
that bad,
he'd probably say,
well, he could do "Update."
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Was that 50 years ago?
Jesus.
[ Laughter ]
Rudy's impression of the Queen
sounds exactly like
his impression of Joe Pesci,
which sounds exactly like
his impression of Kirk Douglas,
at least I think he's doing
a Kirk Douglas impression
judging from his voice.
Maybe Rudy thinks Al Pacino
played Spartacus.
"I'm Spartacus.
Your Spartacus.
This whole damn Colosseum
is Spartacus."
How was that Lorne?
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, why do they bring up
Rudy Giuliani?
Oh, right. You guys are not
going to believe this.
He got subpoenaed.
-We have this breaking
news for you now.
The House Select Committee
investigating
the January 6th Capitol
insurrection has just
subpoenaed four close allies
of Donald Trump,
including Rudy Giuliani.
-These subpoenas now,
they mark
a significant escalation
by this committee,
especially because they're
going after Rudy Giuliani.
Rudy Giuliani now,
of course,
he worked closely
with Trump for years,
and he was leading the effort
to overturn
the 2020 election results.
Of course, he spearheaded
several lawsuits
that were dismissed
in several different courts,
and Giuliani notably
also spoke out at that
Stop the Steal
rally on January 6th.
He called for "trial
by combat,"
so he in particular
has a lot of information
the committee
wants to dig into.
-Oh no, if you're Rudy Giuliani,
you never want to hear
the words dig into.
He's probably having flashbacks
the last time he was
at Ruby Tuesday.
"Hey, will you stop digging
in the salad bar.
It's for paying customers only."
"What?" I thought
it was free for people
named Ruby on Tuesdays."
-"But your name is Rudy."
"Oh, Ruby.
[ Laughter ]
You did it again."
I mean, it's starting
to get ridiculous.
How much legal trouble
can one person be in?
Is Rudy trying to break
the world record?
He's under investigation
by the feds,
he was raided by the FBI,
he's been sued by poll workers
and an election
technology company.
His law license was suspended
in New York and D.C.,
and now he's being subpoenaed.
Next, he's going
to get pulled over
for swerving only to blow
a zero on the breathalyzer.
"Oh, that's very weird.
I thought for sure
you were driving drunk."
"Well, I have
to be pretty stupid
to get a drunk driving
before driving a stolen car."
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
As for the -- [ Laughs ]
As for the actual content
of what really might reveal
to the committee
if he cooperates,
there's a lot we can learn.
After all, he was instrumental
in leading
Trump's effort
to overturn the election.
He spoke at those
press conferences
and the Stop the Steal
rally on January 6th,
where he called
for "trial by combat."
He personally called up
lawmakers
like Alabama Senator
Tommy Tuberville
on the day of the insurrection
to get them to delay
the counting
of electoral votes,
and he helped set up
a command center
in a D.C. hotel with other
Trump allies like Steve Bannon.
I personally can't wait
to see him under oath
because we know from experience
he's not exactly great
when he's giving
sworn testimony.
For example, we have
a videotaped deposition
from a defamation lawsuit filed
by election technology firms
where Rudy straight up admitted
he made public accusations
without any proof.
-We had a report that the heads
of Dominion and Smartmatic
somewhere in the mid teens,
you know, 2013, 2014,
went down to Venezuela
for a get-to-know
meeting with Maduro
so they could demonstrate
to Maduro
the kind of vote fixing
they did for--
for, um, for Chavez.
-You say the heads
of Dominion and Smartmatic?
-Yes, that's what I was told.
Before the press conference,
I was told about it.
Sometimes I go and look myself
online when stuff comes up.
This time I don't have
the time to do it.
It's not my job in
a fast-moving case
to go out and investigate
every piece
of evidence that's given to me.
-No, that is your job.
When you passed
the New York bar,
was it O'Hallaghans?
You're a lawyer,
you have to prove
what you say in court.
You don't even learn that
in year one of law school.
You learn it and act one
of "My Cousin Vinny."
Of course, you probably
hated that movie.
"What is this crap?
Vinny doesn't marry the cousin?"
[ Laughter ]
But this is how it always goes.
These morons make a bunch
of crazy allegations in public,
and then in private when
there are actual consequences,
they admit they're
full of [bleep].
Like, when the Trump campaign
wrote a memo
in private debunking
its own fraud claims,
or when Rudy told the court,
this is not a fraud case.
In fact, you know what
I'd love to see?
I'd love to see the public
Rudy Giuliani
that appears in press
conferences cross-examine
the private Rudy Giuliani
we see in depositions.
-How many fingers do I got up?
Somewhere in the mid teens,
you know, 20, 13, 14,
whatever.
-And yet somehow lucky for him,
Rudy Giuliani is still not in
as much legal trouble
as his former client,
Donald Trump,
who is under multiple
investigations in multiple
states and jurisdictions
examining everything
from the coup attempt
to his private business.
And now the New York
attorney general
has taken one of those
investigations a step further
by releasing public details
of what her investigation
has uncovered so far,
and it's both incredibly damning
and not at all surprising.
-Breaking overnight, New York
State's attorney general
is demanding answers
in her investigation
of the Trump Organization.
Letitia James filed court papers
requesting former
President Trump,
his son Donald Jr.
and daughter Ivanka Trump
to be questioned under oath.
James laid out some of the
evidence against the company
and says that Trump's need
to respond to this.
-What we are learning
from this filing
in this press release tonight
is that the -- the allegations
are that Donald Trump,
Donald Trump Jr.
and Ivanka Trump were
very involved in exaggerating
or misstating statements
of assets and finances
in order to obtain loans,
insurance and tax credits
and to over inflate the value
of various properties.
-You know how when people
are shocked
they spit out their water?
When I heard Donald Trump
exaggerated the value
of his assets
for the purposes of lying
to banks and the IRS,
it was so the reverse
of shocking.
I sucked the water
back into my mouth.
[ Laughter ]
We even filmed it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
We did that together.
I mean, of course,
this guy committed fraud.
His business and former CFO
have already been charged
with tax crimes.
Trump himself paid no income
taxes in 10 out of 15 years,
according to
the New York Times.
He lost a billion dollars
over a decade,
and in 2016 and 2017,
he paid $750 in income taxes.
He paid less in federal
income taxes for an entire year
while he was president
of the United States
than what I paid in rent
for my first apartment
in New York City.
Of course, you have to remember
I moved here in 1851.
It was a studio
and the only entrance
was a third story window
you had to climb
through via ladder
from the smallpox
asylum next door.
It was a small fridge.
Inside the fridge, there was an
even smaller futon.
It was so cold
sleeping in there.
But if you left the door
open for heat,
the light stayed on, so...
Who was the landlord
of that [bleep] anyway?
Ah, [bleep]!
[ Laughter ]
The details published
in this court filing
are also in typical
Trump fashion,
both deeply corrupt and also
not even remotely surprising.
-In court documents
filed late Tuesday,
New York State's Attorney
General Letitia James
said her investigators found
the Trump Organization
repeatedly engaged in fraudulent
or misleading practices.
She cited multiple cases
where the former president
lent his signature
on documents
where she says he inflated
the value of his company
and his own fortune.
James highlighted
several accounts
of how she says the company
inflated its bottom line,
including misrepresenting the
size of Mr. Trump's penthouse,
saying it was triple
its actual size,
leading to a difference
of about $200 million.
In another example,
James says Mr. Trump's company
inflated the value
of his suburban golf club
by millions of dollars
by counting fees
that were never collected.
-Well, of course, he inflated
the value of his golf club.
Remember that picture of Trump
at the omelette bar?
It's different place,
but does that look like
a multimillion dollar
property to you?
That looks like the
continental breakfast at a OK 8.
[ Laughter ]
I bet you all
the little mini cereal boxes
are weird brand name knockoffs
like Frosted Fakes
or Honey Nut Cheeri-No's.
But the frustrating part
of this investigation
is that we've known
some of these details for years.
There have been bombshell
reports in the New York Times
and other places about
all kinds of seemingly,
fraudulent activity
and Trump's former fixer,
Michael Cohen, explained
to Congress under oath
the kinds of details
we're hearing now.
-To your knowledge,
did the president
ever provide inflated assets
to an insurance company?
-Yes.
-Who else knows
that the president did this?
-Allen Weisselberg,
Ron Lieberman
and Matthew Calamari.
-To your knowledge,
was the president interested
in reducing his local
real estate bills, tax bills?
-Yes.
-And how did he do that?
-What you do is you deflate
the value of the asset
and then you put in a request
to the tax department
for a deduction.
-How is it that Congress can get
the president's lawyer
to say under oath
that he committed fraud
and it takes years
before someone
in law enforcement is like,
hey, we think this guy
might have committed fraud.
It's like one of those crime
shows where it takes 10 episodes
for everyone around
the charming British guy
with a mysterious past to say,
huh, do you think maybe
he murdered his secret mistress
who is with the night
of the murder?
Because let me
give you a hint, detective.
If it's modern day Hugh Grant,
he is the killer.
This ain't your romcom
Hugh Grant anymore.
He's the bad boy now,
and I, for one, am here for it.
This is the golden age
of Hugh Grant.
The stammer is gone,
and in its place are the cold,
dead eyes of a killer.
If they remade
"Notting Hill" now,
Julia Roberts
will be missing
and the Bookshop Strangler
would be the only suspect.
They should remake
all of his old movies.
One ticket to "Four Funerals
and a Wedding," please.
[ Laughter ]
It's so obvious it's Hugh Grant.
It's so --
you know obviously it is?
This is how I react when I hear
Hugh Grant is the killer.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
These guys have been committing
their crimes in broad daylight,
and the integrity of our system
relies on holding them
accountable.
Trump and Rudy have exploited
that system for years,
but we have as much evidence
of their guilt in front of us
as we could possibly need.
I don't know what will happen,
but I'm guessing
if the feds ever knock on
Rudy's door to arrest him,
he'll say,
No, I'm not Rudy Giuliani.
-I'm Spartacus.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks and
brings over two million meals
a year to men,
women and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.